en el vídeo anterior empezamos con la
fórmula molecular c3 h 8 y vimos una de
las posibles estructuras de puntos de
lewis que se pueden dibujar que tienen
esa fórmula molecular a partir de esta
estructura de puntos de louis vimos
otras formas de representar la misma
molécula sin embargo no tuvimos tiempo
para hablar de estructuras de enlace
línea por lo tanto vamos a empezar este
vídeo con esta estructura de puntos de
louis y la vamos a convertir en una
estructura de enlace línea si nos
fijamos en el dibujo de la izquierda
está implicando que estos tres carbonos
se encuentran en una línea recta
perfecta sin embargo el dibujo de la
derecha hace un mejor trabajo en mostrar
cómo se ve la molécula realmente esos
carbonos no están en una línea recta
perfecta puedes ver que se doblan de
esta manera
así que cuando estás dibujando una
estructura de enlace línea y tienes una
cadena de carbonos quieres dibujar esa
cadena de carbonos en forma de zig zag
ahora vamos a pensar en los enlaces
carbono hidrógeno si dibujar as cada
enlace carbono hidrógeno en tu clase de
química orgánica te tomaría por siempre
por lo que no dibujamos esos enlaces
cuando dibujamos estructuras de enlace
línea los carbonos todavía están unidos
a estos hidrógenos pero vamos a
ignorarlos para nuestra estructura de
enlace línea sólo para simplificar las
cosas por lo tanto voy a dibujar esta
línea alrededor de los enlaces carbono
hidrógeno
así que vamos a ignorarlos por el
momento y ahora tenemos nuestros 3
carbonos los dibujamos así
y este carbono está unido a un oxígeno y
este oxígeno está unido a un hidrógeno
voy a colocar los pares de electrones
libres en el oxígeno
ahora bien podemos simplificar esto
todavía más podemos dejar de lado esos
carbonos los átomos de carbono todavía
están ahí solo estoy hablando de no
dibujarlas es aquí porque puede ser un
poco confuso así que ahora no dibujamos
las sedes y tampoco dibujamos los pares
de electrones en el oxígeno y tenemos
nuestra estructura de enlace línea esta
es nuestra estructura de enlace línea
contiene la misma información que
nuestra estructura de puntos de louis
pero es mucho más fácil de dibujar nos
toma menos tiempo y te va a ayudar a
través de tu curso cuando estés viendo
reacciones químicas ahora vamos a
analizar algunos carbonos este carbono
en rojo es este carbono de aquí el
carbono sigue estando aquí solamente que
no estamos dibujando la letra c veamos
ahora a nuestros otros carbonos el
carbono en la derecha este carbono en
magenta es este carbono justo aquí y el
carbono de la izquierda lo voy a
circular en color azul es este carbono
el carbono en azul todavía está unido a
otros 3 hidrógenos este carbono en azul
aún está unido a 3 átomos de hidrógeno
sólo los dejamos fuera de nuestra
estructura de enlace línea el carbono en
la derecha sigue estando unido a 3
hidrógenos
pero una vez más no los dibujamos cuando
estamos trazando estructuras de enlace
línea y el carbono en el medio este
carbono en rojo está unido a un o h eso
se puede ver en nuestra estructura de
enlace línea y está unido a un hidrógeno
más por lo tanto sigue habiendo un
hidrógeno unido a este carbono solamente
lo omitimos para que la estructura sea
más fácil de ver así que déjenme borrar
lo que acabo de dibujar aquí muy bien
así que voy a borrar estos hidrógenos
estos hidrógenos están todavía aquí
sabemos que si están ahí
y ahora vamos a practicar para averiguar
cómo funcionan estas estructuras de
enlace línea empecemos por analizar esta
estructura de enlace línea y vamos a
empezar con este carbono en magenta este
carbono en magenta lo voy a representar
de este lado está unido a otro carbono
que es este carbono de aquí por lo tanto
hay un enlace entre esos dos carbonos
déjame dibujar ese enlace
ahora tenemos otro carbono este carbono
en rojo aquí arriba voy a dibujar el
enlace entre estos dos carbonos y luego
vamos a usar verde para el siguiente
carbono así que tenemos un carbono aquí
en verde y por último hay un carbono más
vamos a usar azul obscuro para ese
carbono
tenemos un carbono más aquí en color
azul obscuro y dibujaré este enlace
muy bien hay 5 carbonos en esta molécula
son 5 carbonos así que vamos a escribir
la fórmula molecular sería 65 muy bien
vamos a averiguar cuántos hidrógenos
tenemos para eso es necesario que
recordemos que un átomo de carbono
neutro forma únicamente 4 enlaces así
que vamos a ver cuántos enlaces ya
tenemos vamos a empezar con el carbono
en magenta
el carbono en magenta ya tiene un enlace
y un átomo de carbono neutro forma
cuatro enlaces así que si ese carbono ya
tiene un enlace entonces necesita tres
enlaces a hidrógenos aquí tenemos el
primer enlace a hidrógeno el segundo
enlace y el tercer enlace a hidrógeno
ahora vamos con este carbono de arriba
el de color rojo este carbono ya tiene
un enlace y necesita un total de 4
enlaces por lo que necesita 3 enlaces
más y esos enlaces van a ir a hidrógeno
cierto queda implícito que esos enlaces
son a hidrógenos veamos ahora el carbono
en azul claro cuántos enlaces tiene este
carbono bueno aquí está uno aquí hay
otro y aquí hay otro este carbono ya
tiene tres enlaces así que solo necesita
uno más ahora vamos a ver el carbono en
verde el carbono en verde ya tiene dos
enlaces aquí está uno y aquí está otro
si pensamos que un átomo de carbono
neutro forma cuatro enlaces este átomo
de carbono necesita dos enlaces más y
esos enlaces son a dos hidrógenos y por
último el carbono en azul obscuro el
carbono en azul obscuro ya tiene un
enlace por lo que necesita tres más
así que dibujamos 12
y tres enlaces a hidrógeno así que ahora
hemos dibujado por completo la
estructura de puntos de louis para esta
estructura de enlace línea y cuántos
hidrógenos tenemos en total bueno si los
contamos veremos que hay 12 hidrógenos
en total por lo tanto la fórmula
molecular es 65 h 12
hagamos otro ejemplo veamos la siguiente
estructura de enlace línea y vamos a
centrarnos en nuestros carbonos
empezamos con este carbono aquí en
magenta lo voy a dibujar aquí el carbono
en magenta está unido a otros dos átomos
de carbono voy a dibujar este carbono de
arriba en rojo y hay un enlace entre
estos dos carbonos y hay otro enlace en
este carbono de aquí en color azul claro
vamos a dibujar esos enlaces y vamos a
continuar con nuestros carbonos vamos a
enfocarnos primero en nuestros carbonos
y después volveremos a nuestros
hidrógenos dibujamos este carbono de
aquí en verde y tenemos otro enlace
carbono carbono y luego vamos a utilizar
el color azul obscuro así que tenemos a
este carbono en azul obscuro por aquí
junto con su enlace por aquí y también
tenemos otro carbono por aquí ese
carbono va justo aquí y podemos dibujar
nuestro último enlace el carbono en rojo
está unido a un átomo de claro así que
voy a dibujar a nuestro átomo de cloro
y ahora vamos a pensar en los hidrógenos
comencemos con el carbono en rojo así
que este carbono en rojo cuantos enlaces
tiene bueno tiene 123 enlaces ya cuenta
con tres enlaces por lo tanto necesita
un enlace más y está implícito que ese
enlace va a un hidrógeno por lo que este
carbono está unido a un hidrógeno
ahora vamos a ver el carbono en magenta
cuántos enlaces tiene el carbono en
magenta bueno aquí está uno y aquí está
otro ya tiene dos enlaces por lo que el
carbono en magenta necesidad dos más así
podemos dibujar un hidrógeno aquí y un
hidrógeno aquí es la misma situación
para todos los carbonos que forman el
anillo si vemos este carbono aquí en
azul claro ya cuenta con dos enlaces por
lo tanto necesita dos enlaces más y eso
significa que tiene dos enlaces a
hidrógeno así que vayamos alrededor de
todo el anillo
y agreguemos dos hidrógenos a cada uno
de nuestros átomos de carbono
permítanme asegurarme que utilizó los
colores correctos aquí así que cuál es
la fórmula molecular para este compuesto
bueno tenemos un total de 6 carbonos
cierto 1 2 3 4 5 6 6 6
y cuántos hidrógenos hay en total
tenemos dos hidrógenos en cinco de
nuestros carbonos y luego tenemos otro
por aquí por lo tanto dos veces 5 es 10
más 1 es 11 así que h 11 y luego tenemos
un cloro también por lo tanto la fórmula
molecular de este compuesto sería de 6 h
11 cl
veamos dos ejemplos más
y vamos a empezar con este carbono aquí
en magenta voy a dibujarlo por acá este
carbono en color magenta está unido a
este carbono en azul pero observa que
hay dos enlaces entre estos dos carbonos
el carbono magenta está unido al carbono
en azul pero hay un doble enlace entre
nuestros carbonos y el carbono a la
derecha aquí en rojo tiene un enlace
sencillo hay un enlace sencillo entre el
carbono en azul y el carbono en rojo por
lo tanto para la fórmula molecular hasta
ahora sabemos que hay un total de 3
átomos de carbono en este compuesto
ahora tenemos que pensar en los
hidrógenos sabemos que un átomo de
carbono neutro forma cuatro enlaces el
carbono forma cuatro enlaces cuántos
enlaces tiene el carbono en magenta
bueno aquí hay un enlace y aquí hay otro
enlace por lo tanto el carbono en
magenta necesita dos enlaces más y esos
enlaces deben de ir a dos hidrógenos a
continuación pensemos en el carbono en
azul cuantos enlaces tiene el carbono en
azul aquí está uno aquí hay otro y aquí
tenemos otro
el carbono en azul ya tiene tres enlaces
y necesita uno más dibujemos un enlace
carbono hidrógeno y finalmente el carbón
en rojo ya tiene un enlace por lo que
necesita tres más
así que dibujamos tres enlaces carbono
hidrógeno
de esta manera muy bien cuántos
hidrógenos tenemos en total tenemos seis
hidrógenos por lo tanto la fórmula
molecular es set 3 h 6
y podemos empezar a pensar en los
estados de hibridación aquí ya que si
nos fijamos en este carbono y en este
carbono
sabemos que ambos carbonos tienen una
hibridación sp2 y si esos carbonos
tienen una hibridación esp dados estamos
hablando de una geometría tribunal-
plana en torno a esos átomos y
procuramos mostrar eso en nuestra
estructura de puntos lo mejor que
podemos
aquí tenemos ángulos de aproximadamente
120 grados así que también podemos
incluir la hibridación de nuestros
carbonos ahora vamos a ver esta molécula
de aquí que tiene un triple enlace los
enlaces triples a menudo confunden a los
estudiantes a la hora de dibujar
estructuras de enlace línea así que
vamos a asignar colores a nuestros
carbonos nuevamente vamos a empezar con
este de aquí en magenta voy a dibujar el
carbono en magenta por aquí el carbono
en magenta está unido a este carbono en
azul y hay un enlace sencillo entre los
dos carbonos
y después hay un enlace entre el carbono
en azul y este carbono aquí en rojo este
carbono en rojo hay un enlace sencillo
entre ellos el carbono en rojo está
unido a un carbono más en el lado
opuesto de nuestro triple enlace así que
el carbono en azul está aquí hay un
triple enlace entre el carbono en rojo y
el carbono en azul
así que ahora que hemos dibujado a
nuestros carbonos tenemos 4 carbonos por
lo tanto esto sería c4 hasta ahora para
la fórmula molecular
ahora tenemos que pensar en los
hidrógenos el carbono en la gente ya
tiene un enlace por lo tanto necesita
tres enlaces más dibujemos tres enlaces
carbono hidrógeno
este carbono en azul ya tiene dos
enlaces aquí hay uno y aquí hay otro así
que el carbono en azul necesita dos más
y qué pasa con el carbono en rojo bueno
el carbono en rojo tiene un enlace 2
y 4
el carbono en rojo ya tiene cuatro
enlaces así que el carbono en rojo no
tiene ningún hidrógeno en él en absoluto
y finalmente el carbono en azul el
carbono en azul tiene tres enlaces 1 2 3
ya tiene tres enlaces lo que significa
que el carbono en azul necesita un
enlace más y ese enlace va a un
hidrógeno así que ahora que tenemos
todos nuestros hidrógenos eso es un
total de 6 hidrógenos vamos a completar
la fórmula molecular c4 h 6
y una vez más pensemos en la hibridación
este carbono y ese carbono
ambos tienen una hibridación esp por lo
que sabemos que la geometría es lineal
en torno a esos carbonos y es por eso
que dibujamos esta parte de la molécula
como una línea recta en nuestras
estructuras de enlace línea es debido a
la geometría
estamos tratando de reflejar la
estructura de la molécula lo mejor que
podemos práctica tus estructuras de
enlace línea porque son de suma
importancia para todo lo que vas a hacer
en química orgánica